[Music]  you're here to save myself I understand  it's your birthday yeah  the party's just getting started his  name is Callan Minj  we've traced his bloodline back 500  years to the Assassin's Creed Cal as  anyone in the world knows or cares you  no longer exist what is this place  this is your second chance  [Music]  what do you want from me  your past you're about to enter the  Animus what you see hear and feel are  the memories of your ancestor he's been  dead for 500 years wait a minute  welcome to the Spanish Inquisition  what I saw in there and fill me  [Music]  it was  you're watching you waiting to see who  you are  I believe you are destined for great  things that's fine now  we'll work in the dark turn up the  lights  we are assassins  I'm beginning to like this  I think Assassin's Creed has a really  deep concept an idea which is going back  into time having some sort of  relationship with the ancestor that's  come before you